لا تجري الرياح التطورات الميدانيه بما
تشتهيه اشرعه موسكو خصوصا على
جبهاتسك رئيس الروسي الذيمر بوتين يقر
بصعوبه الوضع في هذه المناطق اضافه لوجيا
عن سيادته اليوم تواجه روسيا التحدي نفسه
مره اخرى وعلى خط لمواجهه في العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه يظهر الجنود والضباته
والمتطوعون امثله استثنائيه عن الشجاعه
والتضحيه
التطورات والتصريحات في موسكو فضل رئيس
الاوكراني ان يزور خط الجبهه في الشرق
اوكرانيا وتحديدا جبهه الملتهبه منذ شهور
فالمعارك في بخموت وفقزنسكي بات التكسير
الجيش الروسي ومن وصفهم بالمرتزقه الذين
جنتهم روسيا وتقع بخموت على اطراف دولي
يصلها بمدن مثل
كراماتسك ويتابع مساره نحو منطقه
الشمس
المكان الاكثر سخونه على خط المواجهه
باكمله والمعارك تجري على خط بطوله 2300
كيلو متر منذ ما يويار والاحتلال ويحاول
دخول محمود لكن الوقت يمر وقواتنا هي التي
تلحق الخسائر بالجيش الروسي لقد فقدت
روسيا 99 الف من جنودها في اوكرانيا
وقريبا ستصلوا خسائرهم
لا يمكنها تجاوز حقائق على الارض يميزها
قصف اوكراني
الروسيه مؤشرنا على قدرتك على نقل المعارك
خارج حدودها ولو رمزيا فقد اعلد حاكم
مقاطعه بريانس كروسيه التي تقع على بال
نحو 380 كلم غربيه موسكو قصف القوه
الاوكرانيه لبلده سوزوكي الحدوديه ما تسبب
في انقطاع الجزئيه للتيار الكهربائي كانت
ساهم حكم مقاطعه بالجرود الروسيه الجيش
الاوكراني بقص مدينه شيبيتين والمتاخمه
للحدود الروسيه مع رانيا متى سبب في
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن ثلث سكان
المدينه بالمقابل اكد الجيش الاوكراني
استمرار القصف الروسي على مقاطعه ميكولاي
فوديني برو وسابرو جي جنبا وخاركي في
الشرق
الاوكراني مواقع داخل التراب الروسي
ياتيني بين ملتقى بوتين في موسكو حكام
الاقاليم الاوكرانيه الاربعه التي ضمتها
روسيا مؤخرا الى اراضيها لبحث ما سمته
موسكو لعمليه العسكريه وملفات تكامل ضمن
الاتحاد الفيدرالي الروسي كلها مؤشرته
جوله جديده في الحرب المستمره تشيي بتغير
في موازينها ولكن ايضا في رهاناتها وربما
اطرافها فالرئيس البيلاروسيا اليكساندر
لوكاشيينكو قال انه لا يمكن لبلاده ضمانه
امنها دون مساعده روسيا مؤكدا نشر منظومه
الصواريخ اس 4 واسكندر روسيه الصنع على
الاراضي البلاسيا قد يكون كل ذلك رسائل في
غمره اعلانات غربيه عن دعم عسكري مستمر
لكيف لكن يبدو لفصل الشتاء ايضا وراء
حسابات كل الاطراف ضمن معادله التقدم
والسيطره